bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis sur france 3 avec aujourd'hui
quatre voies pour réagir à une très
grande émotion après les multiples
naufrages de bateaux chargés de migrants
en méditerranée est ce une vague
d'immigration sans précédent que peuvent
faire les pays européens la gestion
française du dossier de l'immigration
est elle encore adapté quatre invités
donc pour débattre et répondre à ces
questions et député ump de l'yonne
guillaume larrivé bonjour bonjour vous
avez précédemment travaillé avec brice
hortefeux au ministère de l'immigration
le député socialiste de côte-d'or
laurent grandguillaume bonjour bonjour
vous connaissez aussi très près ce
dossier puisque vous êtes tous les ans
l'auteur d'un rapport parlementaire sur
le sujet dans le gard et que vous
représentez la ligue des droits de
l'homme
bonjour nos jours on vous voit souvent
en première ligne sur ces dossiers et
daniel réty bonjour bonjour vous êtes
ici pour essorer s'enlève refoulement
qui assure le soutien juridique et
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'asile
bonjour à vous et merci à tous les
quatre d'être là l'événement n'était pas
nouveau pourrait-on dire un naufrage de
migrants dans la méditerranée mais cette
fois son ampleur a sidéré l'europe
les nations unies et l'union européenne
tout le monde se penche sur le sujet
mais moi j'ai d'abord envie de vous
demander ce que vous en avez pensé en
voyant les images et paul garric vivent
ou qui y oeuvrer au contact de ces
populations comment avez vous réagi
passée l'émotion surtout que nous on
accuse souvent les survivants et cd que
les liens forts concrets avec ces
personnes
la première chose si c'est terrible à
quel point aujourd'hui il ya un déni de
leur humanité
après on aura certainement à dire le
pourquoi et le comment mais oui comment
ils sont si peu aujourd'hui dans le
débat public habituellement considérés
dans toute leur humanité
laurent guillot même question oui en
tout cas ce qui
d'abord un drame humain bien sûr et je
crois que d'abord ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'on c'est un drame qui
par son ampleur effectivement c'est une
véritable tragédie mais en même temps
chaque jour
en fait on a des g des personnes qui
disparaissent en méditerranée à cause de
filières en fin de compte qui exploitent
la misère
il y a aujourd'hui des filières
organisées qui exploitent la misère
humaine et jusqu'à conduire à la mort
mais c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
combattre
bien évidemment on va en parler bien sûr
d'y arriver était très forte émotion
elle et elle est très forte
évidemment moi j'ai des souvenirs il ya
quelques années déjà d'avoir accompagné
de ministres de l'intérieur de l'époque
à toulon où les corps d'un certain
nombre de migrants qui avait été repêché
par la marine française était non pas
rapatriés mais ramenés vers vers notre
notre pays émotion mais surtout besoin
d'action besoin d'action dans l'intérêt
de la france dans le respect des
personnes mais aussi dans l'intérêt de
la france est de cela je pense donc il
faut que nous débattions quelle doit
être la politique d'immigration dans
l'intérêt de nos compatriotes dans
l'intérêt des européens dans le respect
des personnes
c'est un sujet extrêmement compliqué
mais pense vraiment qu'il ya urgence on
a démarré la télé comme les
prédécesseurs cette hausse est ça
toujours c'est vraiment une grande
émotion c'est quelque fois plus que de
l'émotion c'est vraiment chez moi de la
colère parce que ces personnes-là gens
courtois aussi souvent sur le continent
africain puisque je me rends
régulièrement est bon quand on connaît
un petit peu la situation de certains
n'a pas bon c'est vrai que retrouver ces
gens comme ça ceux décédés dans des
conditions épouvantables moi c'est cette
émotion mais c'est aussi de la colère
alors vous me le dire je rebondis parce
que vous venez de dire je me rends
régulièrement là bas est-ce que de votre
point de vue ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est quelque chose qui existe
depuis des mois des années
ou est ce que c'est un phénomène très
nouveau qui accentue et qui est plus
fort ça existe depuis de nombreuses
années mais là je pense qu'il y a des
éléments notamment à revenir sans doute
placer détails mais d un vêtement de
deux conflits qui font que les gens sont
vraiment acculé au bord de la
méditerranée et donc sur ce board côte
que ce soit au maghreb que ce soit en
afrique noire aussi et donc ils sont
arrivés là et y'a plus rien sauf la
traverse alors ce qu'on a entendu c'est
finalement plusieurs propositions entre
ceux qui
10 il faut augmenter les opérations de
secours pour aller secourir les gens ce
qu'ils disent il faut organiser des
camps dans le côté de la méditerranée en
libye l'europe qui dit il faudrait aller
détruire les bateaux des passeurs moi
j'ai envie de vous demander de votre
point de vue il faut faire quoi
le garric d'abord je crois pour relire
faut faire quoi il faut bien partir de
la cause et ceux qui tuent c'est d'abord
la politique européenne telle qu'elle
est menée
c'est à dire on a créé des voix
extrêmement dangereuse parce que si les
gens fuient ils savent comme un ménisque
qui prend c'est parce que c'est pas
possible de faire autrement a des fois
quand les journalistes lui demandent
d'où viennent les gens on leur dit
regardez la carte des guerres et des
guides effective des dictatures et vous
avez la carte de ce que fuient les gens
je crois et c'est un droit fondamental
garanti par les traités internationaux
suis d'échapper aux guerres et aux
dictatures
à partir de ce moment là libre il faut
respecter ce droit
et plus on voudra faire de l'europe une
forteresse 1 ça marchera pas et de on
envoie les gens la mort c'est ça qui
crée des dangers dont évidemment des
gangsters profite mais le fond du fond
c'est respectons le droit international
facilitons le respect du droit sert que
des gens qui demandent l'asile puissent
venir le demande et par des moyens de
transport sécurisé et aussi je crois il
faut le dire en relativisant parce qu'on
nous présente ça comme si c'était entend
même invasion
jeudi encore un ami passe un article est
paru d'une spéciale de la question dans
la croix ya deux jours 80 90 % des
réfugiés dans le monde sont dans les
pays en voie développement dans les pays
les plus pauvres
saleh quels sont les pays qui ont le
plus de réfugiés aujourd'hui le pakistan
l'iran le kenya peut-être aussi la
jordanie la turquie qui est un grand
succès et la turquie l'europe ou les usa
c'est rien c'est la seriat sait même pas
même pas 1% et à partir de là je crois
il faut relativiser c'est à dire oui ces
gens il fuit parce qu'ils peuvent pas
faire autrement il y à des traités
internationaux qui doivent leur assurer
la sécurité assureront
leur la sécurité pour faire vivre ce
droit en guise qui empêchait les
passeurs faire des camps parce qu'il
gardait les gens en libye sur le
territoire africain ce qui m'indigne un
peu par depuis plusieurs années c'est
cette tendance dans la classe politique
française en fin de compte à agiter le
chiffon de l'immigration pour faire peur
ou alors sans jamais traité
véritablement les questions de fond et
c'est très bien vous organiser ce débat
parce que on va pouvoir enfin aborder
ces sujets quand on en débat dans
l'hémicycle
guillaume larrivé est aussi présent
lorsqu'il de débat sur ces questions là
il ya très peu de monde en fin de compte
et c'est bien dommage alors que ce sont
des culs équivaudrait à tout le monde
moi je suis internationaliste donc moi
je ne pense pas que l'on puisse régler
les problèmes uniquement en se
focalisant sur la france seule ou
l'europe seule il y avait effectivement
des pays dans le monde dans lequel il ya
des conflits
il ya des déplacements de population
liés à des enjeux climatiques avec des
difficultés bien sûr quant à l'accès aux
matières premières quand aux ressources
vitales
donc oui il ya des déplacements de
population ces déplacements de
populations comment peut-on les réguler
c'est ça la question
en fin de compte et comment éviter que
des rires des mafias des réseaux qui
profitent de la traite des femmes et des
hommes est bien puisse prospérer
donc il faut à la fois lutter fermement
contre ces réseaux les démanteler et
donc en france nous avons progressé
d'ailleurs en la matière par rapport à
des politiques sont-ils mise en place de
lutte contre ces filières organisées
on doit le faire aussi au niveau
européen la lutte et ou bien sûr dans la
méditerranée avec les moyens maritimes
mais aussi il faut se dire que oui
l'asile par exemple la question de
l'asile la clé dans la protection
d'individus qui peuvent être menacés
dans leur propre pays et qu'une question
fondamentale d'ailleurs qui date de
notre héritage de la révolution
française et donc je crois que la glace
il faut répondre c'est une base ça va
parce qu'un pays va être fermé avec des
barbelés ça existe en corée du nord
est-ce que les gens sont heureux en
corée du nord je ne pense pas ça existe
au savoy les états unis sont heureux
parce qu'ils existent dans beaucoup
d'endroits du monde
est-ce qu'ils sont toujours pas ce qu'il
ya des miradors il ya des barbelés non
donc il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui il y à des personnes en
difficulté il y à des personnes qui se
déplacent parce qu'elles fuient leur
pays pour des raisons qui sont claires
que l'on connaît bien donc il faut à la
fois organiser l'accueil
là où c'est possible bien sûr parce
qu'il faut aussi que nous assumons notre
responsabilité
maintenant il faut que nous traitions si
les problèmes à la source on peut pas
continuez comme cela avec un océan de
misère avec les difficultés d'un
continent qui sont proches de nous en
faisant comme s'il n'y avait rien en
raisonnant avec en se regardant le
nombril guillaume larrivé 1,79 la france
a accueilli plus de 100000 boat people
qui venait du cambodge du vietnam je
crois que le chiffre à l'époque c'est un
million trois cent mille personnes qui
ont été accueillies dans les pays
industrialisés pourquoi est-ce que ont
finalement on mène pas la même opération
aujourd'hui avec les gens qui arrivent
de syrie aux qui arrive de certains pays
africains en guerre première remarque
l'année dernière il ya eu une
augmentation de + 150 % du nombre
d'entrées irrégulière devant l'entrée de
clandestins vers l'europe
j'invente pas ce chiffre c'est le
dernier chiffre de l' agence frontex
dans le même temps le nombre des
demandes d'asile vers l'europe
c'est-à-dire le nombre des demandes de
personnes qui disent qu'elles sont des
réfugiés politiques a augmenté de + 69
pour cent il ya un seul chiffre qui
baisse c'est le chiffre des reconduites
effective des expulsions vers les pays
d'origine
je donne ces chiffres d'accord avec vous
mais s'il ne veux pas m'arrêter c'était
la globalité de l'opération dont je
parlais guillaume larrivé le fait que
les états lance pas une opération pour
accueillir les gens qui arrivent le
bihan guerre je donne ces chiffres là
parce qu'il faut être extrêmement précis
lomé remarques
deuxième remarque on est tous d'accord
sur les principes théoriques si j'ose
dire là où sa page c'est au plan
opérationnel
moi ma conviction pour avoir été
praticiens de ces questions là et
d'avoir ma part de responsabilité dans
les années 2007 2012 où j'ai essayé
comme directeur de cabinet adjoint du
ministre de l'intérieur et de
l'immigration nous en occuper
concrètement gouvernement actuel essaie
de s'en occuper
concrètement si moi je constate qu'il ya
plein de choses qui bloque et notamment
au plan européen
ça ne marche pas je développe juste deux
phrases en 2008 la france présidé
l'union européenne le ministre de
l'époque a pris son bâton de pèlerin
d'aller voir les 26 autres ou 27 autres
ministres de l'intérieur de
l'immigration et on a conclu un grand
document qui s'appelait le pacte
européen sur l'immigration et l'asile à
l'unanimité les socialistes les
communistes les gens de droite plutôt
dur les centristes le centre droit tout
le monde tous les pays européens totale
qu'est ce que
ce que vous croyez que ça vraiment
marché ça n'a pas marché donc je pense
qu'il faut tout changer et j'ai
personnellement ça n'est qu'une
proposition personnelle je le porte
parole de personnes dans ce débat
d'autres que moi comme député je pense
qu'il faut raisonner désormais non plus
à l'échelle des 27 mai à l'échelle de ce
que j'appellerais un g7 des pays
européens qui concentre le plus de flux
d'immigration concrètement si nous les
allemands le royaume s'est pas nous les
premiers les pannes ou l'espagne avec
les quatrièmes en effet quatrième en
europe
cet ensemble cet ensemble de g7 et je
m'arrête l'art de faire cet ensemble de
g7 européen il est une politique
extrêmement intégrés ils soient capables
d'aller négocier avec les pays d'origine
avec les pays de transit pour organiser
et pour réduire au bout du compte les
flux de nombreuses et moi pays d'origine
la libye par exemple d'appliquer ce
qu'on appelle ap transiter dans les
wilayas du pays il n'ya pas n'y a pas
d'état en réalité en libye à la suite de
l'opération de l'onu que la france avait
avec d'autres angles en bien vite le
problème c'est que si on parle de g7 par
exemple on pourrait prendre la situation
de malte maltais dans l'europe
donc je veux dire qu'on prend on traite
pas la situation spécifique de malte qui
accueille de nombreux réfugiés soit
absolument avec des difficultés qu'il
faut absolument que malte évidemment ce
qui est un exemple là dedans mais c'est
un exemple soit complètement je branche
est fort et je résolus au niveau des 27
seulement il faut sortir des égoïsmes
nationaux quand je parle d' égoïsme
national ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
défendre la nation
oui il faut défendre la nation seulement
en fait il faut aussi savoir la dépasser
parfois et sur cette question là en
particulier si on reste uniquement sur
les intérêts nationaux les uns et des
autres on ne règlera pas la question que
j'attirais l'attention là on a qu'à lire
les musiques qui sont communes sur le
fait que la tendance lourde aujourd'hui
c'est que en europe c'est plutôt des
partis qui font leur succès sur
l'opposition à l'immigration qui sont en
train de progresser
je pense en particulier à tout le nord
de l'europe par exemple à l'allemagne à
tous ces pays a peut-être donc on peut
pas dire ça parce que je mens et parce
qu'ils sont majoritaires sur le plan
culturel aujourd'hui les plans des idées
et même sur le plan politique que pour
autant moi je vais changer les idées moi
je ne marchais au sondage marque de
l'américaine moi j'assume mes positions
sur ce sujet là voilà et je n'en
changerai pas parce que justement il y
aurait des majorités politiques qui
seraient plus réactionnaires ou je ne
sais quoi je pense que sur ces questions
d'abord le reset jour d'assimiler
l'immigration à des questions d'identité
on y reviendra je pense mais parce que
c'est aussi les dérives que le concept
il faut rester sur les question c'est
comment on traite
la question humanitaire et pour la
traiter il faut aussi regarder en dehors
de l'europe ce qui se passe sur le
continent africain notamment aux
particuliers et je constate que l'union
européenne en maintenant ses dents dans
cette matière un peu réduit ses
ambitions
parce qu'on peut pas dire qu'elle soit
très présente aujourd'hui sur la
question d' espace méditerranéen en
matière de coopération en matière de
coopération décentralisée avec le
continent africain c'est bien dommage
l'anel réty des gens que vous voyez pour
la plupart est ce que c'est des gens
aujourd'hui qui viennent de pays en
guerre et on va dire qu'ils tombent sous
le coup de la convention internationale
des droits de l'homme sur l'accueil des
réfugiés ou est ce qu'en réalité la
situation elle est souvent plus
compliqué que ça moins nette que ça
c'est une question très ouvert la
plupart ce sont quand même des gens qui
arrivent de lieux où il y à des conflits
et est donc
sont dans une situation telle que on
entend en tant que personne ils sont
menacés
les familles sont menacées et s'ils
quittent le territoire c'est parce que
bon peuvent pas faire autrement
la plupart et la plupart que ce soit
d'ailleurs venant de l'afrique ou de
l'afrique subsaharienne surtout et puis
plus largement même de l'est
la question que j'avais envie de vous
poser à tous les quatre c'est quand on
voit ces dernières années dans une ville
comme dijon qui peut être un exemple
villes moyennes de province
on a vu des images qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir des gens obligés de
s'installer dans des locaux vides dans
des squats des files d'attentes de gens
étrangers très nombreux paul garrigues
qu'est ce qui a changé
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui a
changé est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
plus de gens qui souhaitent immigrer
vous venir en france
est ce que ça veut dire que les
conditions ont changé qu'est ce qui a
changé déjà le plus haut beaucoup
relativiser
j'ai là un document nous a servi xj les
images je parlais de visuels un dans ma
question justement moi j'ai mes défauts
visuels quand on a des chiffrages à
visuels de l'évolution par exemple la
demande d'asie dont nous a dit elle a
augmenté de 86% depuis 2007
d'accord c'est le chiffre historique le
plus bas elle a diminué depuis 2004 faut
raison garder ça toujours fait comme ça
la demande d'asile
après oui ça fait un peu peur un peu
froid dans le dos quand on entend ça
parce que notre peuple quand j'entends
encore dire à tous types de revenir ce
qu'a dit il faut discuter que les pays
d'origine je rappelle quand même pays
d'origine en a en france dirigé par un
monsieur poursuivi par la cpi pour
crimes contre l'humanité
c'est avec lui qu'on va négocier les
droits de l'homme c'est ça le fond du
problème
kaka va le rappeler alors quand vous
dites ce qui s'est passé à dijon il ya
une concentration à dijon lit à deux
chariots vient de province ont été
nommés à dijon n'a eu alors deux choses
comme une chose particulier du général
la chose particulière je pensais une
mauvaise gestion administrative où tout
le monde toute la bourgogne devaient
venir faire son dossier donné ses
enfants
à dijon sa concentré à dijon par rapport
aux autres départements
et deuxième chose qui a amené à un
moment donné un afflux important dijon
c'est la chute de kadhafi si vous voulez
et c'est pour ça qu'on a très peur quand
on entend aussi certaines choses qui se
dit qu'est ce qu'avait fait l'europe
représentée par monsieur berlusconi faut
toujours être représentée par les
meilleurs elle avait négocié avec
kadhafi kadhafi retenait les migrants
subsahariens dans des conditions
épouvantables souvent quand il est tombé
l'allégeance sont sauvés et il arrivait
beaucoup de monde dacquois dijon et
depuis ça s'est assez d'ailleurs c'est
toujours ce qu'on dit on nous parle des
fours d'appel d'air dans dix jours le
fond du poème c'est pas l'appel d'air
c'est l'effet de souffle c'est pourquoi
les gens non fuir les c'est de là qu'il
faut partager leur trouver des solutions
médium l'arrivée qui voulaient répond
rapide roland guillod faut être très
très concret en 2014 en france il ya
entre 200000 et 300 mille immigrés
nouveaux qui sont entrés
c'est à peu près 200 milles de manière
légale c'est comme une ville comme
bordeaux et puis c'est aussi influent
illégal notamment parce qu'il ya des
demandes d'asile et ensuite vont être
rejetés
est ce qu'on appelle des déboutés c'est
à dire des personnes qui en fait n'ont
aucun droit regard de la loi française
de se maintenir en france et c'est un
vrai problème évidemment la cour des
comptes il ya quelques semaines a rendu
un rapport qui est extrêmement
inquiétant 99% écrit la cour des comptes
des personnes qui sont déboutés c'est à
dire qu'on pas le droit de séjourner en
france n'ont pas le droit d'être
maintenue on n'arrive pas le
gouvernement actuel et peut-être aussi
les précédents à les renvoyer vers leur
pays d'origine
alors comment fait-on et c'est là où je
dis vraiment qu'il faut tout changer il
faut changer de braquet faut une
législation qui soit beaucoup moins
attractive et il faut d'abord et ça je
veux le dire à mon collègue député
laurent grandguillaume il faut d'abord
se mettre d'accord sur un objectif
moi je propose qu'on est d'abord comme
objectif de réduire l'immigration vers
la france
est ce qu'on est prêt à assumer d'abord
cet objectif de réduction et ensuite de
s'en donner
opérationnel juridique diplomatique de
manière très concrète vous savez quand
la gauche arrive en juillet 2012 digne
en mêlée et qu'elle décide par exemple
de rendre totalement gratuit les soins
accordés aux clandestins avec ce qu'on
appelle l'aide médicale d'état
en supprimant un forfait qu'on appelait
le ticket modérateur qu'on avait créé
quelques années avant il faut pas
s'étonner qu'ensuite vous ayez en effet
un dispositif d'appel d'air c'est à dire
une augmentation très importante du
nombre des allocataires juste un mois
pas plus attractif en or à vous parler
de quotas guillaume larrivé est-ce que
c'est même pour des gens qu'ils viennent
d'un pays en guerre et qui sont tout à
fait dans les critères de l'asile en ce
moment vous savez bien que je refuserais
y ait des gens qui sont des réfugiés au
titre de la convention des droits de
l'homme on a sur cette question de
l'asile politique c'est-à-dire de
l'accueil en france des combattants de
la liberté
on a une tradition on a des procédures
bon les personnes dont je vous parle qui
sont des déboutés
ça veut dire concrètement que l'ofpra
office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides
puis une juridiction qui s'appelle la
cour nationale du droit d'asile avec des
juges indépendants et à l'intérieur un
membre du haut conseil des réfugiés le
hr et puis ensuite le conseil d'état qui
est un autre juge indépendant toute
cette procédure là avec des tas de
recours dans tous les sens tous les
praticiens le savent
ça veut dire que après tous ses recours
là il ya effectivement 75 % des demandes
qui sont rejetés ce qui veut dire que la
demande d'asile est devenu en réalité
une machine à fabriquer des clandestins
et moi mon sujet comme députée nationale
comme député français à l'assemblée
nationale c'est bien sûr de respecter
ces personnes mais c'est aussi de
défendre le droit de la france à choisir
qui elle veut accueillir sur son
territoire
michel rocard il ya 25 ans disait qu'on
pouvait certes accueillir une partie de
la misère du monde n'est pas toute la
misère du ma phrase sonne encore moi si
je peux me permettre
en fait d'apporter quelques précisions
quand même j'ai trouvé donné quelques
chiffres
pourquoi parce que d'abord la théorie
d'appel d'air si on on sue la théorie
d'appel d'air ça va dire que quand
nicolas sarkozy a tenu des discours très
dur par rapport à l'immigration
normalement on aurait dû avoir moins de
demandeurs d'asile ici la théorie
d'appel d'arrêter vrai or entre 2007
donc et 2000
nous on a eu plus 60% ce demandeur c'est
à dire que la théorie d'appel d'air ne
fonctionne pas non vraiment il ya plus
là dessus je vais donc cette théorie ne
vois pas ce qu en fait ce sont ce sont
des discours parce que le problème est
d'ailleurs c'est dans mes rapports
le problème c'est quoi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a une embolie du
système il ya eu effectivement il ya
beaucoup de demandeurs seulement le
délai de traitement des demandes et
rennes on peut dire que parfois on va
lire une personne au bout de trois ans
quatre ans de procédure vous devez
quitter le territoire
pendant ce temps en fait il y a un coût
aussi pour la nation française
or si cela était mieux gérer si le délai
était plus court
eh bien on pourrait à la fois être plus
digne vis-à-vis des personnes en même
temps étant ferme par rapport à la règle
il ya une règle il faut la respecter
vous pouvez rester ou non sur le
territoire et on a toute la règle passé
en moyenne de 4,7 pas assez de moyens
pour examiner les drôlesses le problème
c'est que en fait le système tel qu'il a
été
on va dire parce qu'à dix vont vous
parler des défis attendent mais les
files d'attentes en préfecture pourquoi
c'est parce que le système d'accueil a
été régionalisée c'est l'autre jour au
lendemain a dit maintenant tous les
demandeurs sont accueillis à dijon alors
qu'avant on faisait par département et
donc du jour en masse a été transformé
donc moi ce que j'ai demandé par exemple
ce que j'ai proposé c'est qu'on puisse
revenir à une départementalisation cd
revenir à une gestion locale
départementale
il ya des d'abord des capacités
d'hébergement des différents
départements pour les gérer par contre
quand quand on donne des chiffres ont
dit deux cent mille deux cent mille
personnes qui vient en france par contre
il faut être précis parce que sur 200
milles il ya 90 mille personnes qui
donnent dans le cadre de l'immigration
familiale
d'accord nous 60 millions d étudiants
donc les étudiants il est effectivement
il ya des puits en france mais nous
aussi nos propres étudiants français
vous réduisez les études qui sont les
faux espions faut vraiment parler les
demandeurs d'asile par ailleurs
effectivement donc sans contenu dans les
200 milles et puis en fait l'immigration
dite économique elle est résiduel donc
il faut faire attention parce que quand
on assène des chiffres comme ça de son
bidon l'impression que à 200 milles de
brazil qui arrivent en france il ya des
demandeurs d'asile il ya aussi des
étudiants
il ya aussi des personnes des situations
sont différentes il n'y a pas que des
personnes qui viennent dans le cadre
d'une demande
une réponse technique de guillaume
larrivé les courtes parce que je me suis
engagé à donner la parole aux taux de
survie sur la demande d'asile
il faut dire les choses de manière très
précise sans être trop long dans les
années 90 très hausse forte hausse des
demandes d'asile avec notamment un
système qui s'appelait l'asile
territoriales qui avait été créée par
monsieur jospin dans les années 2003
2008 sa baisse notamment sous l'effet
des réformes de monsieur de villepin de
monsieur sarkozy en 2003 2004 en
souviens j'étais au cabinet je rédigeais
les textes et là on a réussi
effectivement faire baisser la demande
et il ya eu depuis
en effet une augmentation à nouveau dès
les années 2008 2009
et ça c'est plutôt accéléré de ressasser
le constat ça c'est le constat ne
satisfait personne personne ne peut nier
que globalement on a une augmentation
des flux et qu'il faut y faire face ce
qui me surprend un peu je respecte
laurent grandguillaume g que c'est un
député sérieux extrêmement travailleur
très actif et on appartient à la même
promotion la même génération de députés
qui veulent faire des choses
concrètement et sérieusement et pas
d'une peine génération de bateleur de
foire
bon ce que je regrette un peu dans votre
propos laurent grandguillaume c'est
presque au fond 1 1
un constat sans solution c'est à dire
est ce que vous voulez oui ou non
diminuer les flux est ce qu'on a subi
une réduction de l'immigration vers la
france c'est la première question à se
poser
je constate que françois hollande
n'assume pas cet objectif moi je veux
d'abord qu'on assume cet objectif et
qu'ensuite on se donne concrètement les
moyens de réduire l'immigration
si on se fixe pas cet objectif on n'y
arrivera jamais sur les chiffres 1 que
je partage claude gijon je préciserai
mais même ce qu'on appelle les raisons
familiales
l'essentiel c'est pas de regroupement
familial c'est les mariages de français
avec des étrangers à moins d' interdire
c'est pas moi j'ai une soeur qui s'est
mariée avec un allemand un tel commis un
péché contre la france mangeur encore le
droit de se marier avec qui veulent
enfin on peut espérer mais c'est ça les
premiers c'est les étudiants les
mariages le coeur du défi sont pas les
mariages franco allemand va vraiment le
sujet
mais quelle que soit à 20 à - serait que
j'ai une conception où ma soeur aurait
marianne africa j'aurais été aussi
content que si elle est mariée à un
allemand mais chaque à ces
représentations à la matière oui donc
réduire biome arrivé alors réduire
justement réduire ou alors réduire
bonjour d'hier comme sur l'asile parce
que j'entends un peu des choses moi qui
me frappe dans le conseil d'état dont
les gens ne vont pas au conseil d'état
je suis membre du conseil d'état vient
des perceuses et non jugé selon monsieur
pendant trois ans des années 2002 à 2005
j'ai jugé manque de conseil d'état avec
mes collègues de très nombreuses
affaires des îles on exerce l'essentiel
sa race est d'assembler champagne en
témoigne le vrai problème en france et
qui nous est le fond du problème c'est
le taux d'acceptation extrêmement faible
et qui ne vient pas ce total les
chiffres qu'on avait sur 2012 le taux à
l'eau frette et de 14 5%
la moitié du taux européens le taux de
la norvège est à 60% et la norvège a
beaucoup plus de demandeurs d'asile que
nous en proportion de la population
elle s'en porte pas plus mal ils ont
compris aussi l'intérêt humain et
économique d'en avoir
donc ça veut dire que les critères sont
pas les mêmes ça veut dire qu'on finisse
par alors pour vous donner des exemples
ce que si vous voulez et c'est là aussi
en 30 ans et moi je n'ai entendu mt
préfet lire ce qu'ils ont refusé qu'on
disait de la frontière sur quoi je
répondais d'accord monsieur oublie
d'accord montrez nous où est la
frontière entre la côte d'or et la
somalie ou l'erythrée vous aurez du mal
quand même
et c'est des choses très concrètes moi
je peux vous prouve par les le cam
encore qu'on a vu la semaine dernière
quand vous avez une dame qui arrive du
congo rdc où on sait que le viol et la
torture sur un mode de gouvernance du
gouvernement kabila ou quand même la
dernière discussion plénière manif à
kinshasa c'est combien de centaines de
mort y avait et que cette dame vous dis
20 mois jette emprisonné j'étais
torturée violée qu'elle est bardé de
certificats médicaux qui attestent en
tout cas et qu'elles voient refuser
l'asile parce qu'elle peut pas approuver
parce que le système de l'asile ou des
dans la version la charge de la preuve
revient souvent non dits les faits
faudrait que les trouver des bourreaux
qu'est la bonne idée de données des
certificats de persécution et on voit
des gens qui arrivent des pires
dictatures des relais c'est d'erythrée
du soudan qui refusent l'asile a
évidemment on est dans une impasse
totale
à moins de penser qu'ils vont retourner
à lampedusa vers du stop en sens inverse
de votre bateau qui leur prêtent qu'est
ce que vous allez faire les renvoyer à
leurs bourreaux sait même pas possible
matériellement dans certains cas et je
crois c'est bien là dessus qu'il faut se
poser le problème
dernière chose comme sur les soldes
migratoires de récuser dessus
il faut aussi qu'on soit quand même
réalisé les derniers chiffres qu'on
avait ce que c'est bien il ya des
entrées et des sorties les derniers six
mois que j'ai vu qu'ils étaient en 2013
le solde migratoire pour la france était
positif de 54 mille personnes alors
quand on ne parlait pas de grand
remplacement je vais tout petits calculs
pour ça représente 10% de la population
il faudrait cent vingt ans ce rythme là
bon il n'y a pas d'urgence tout va bien
que non tout va pas bien parce qu'on
refuse le droit d'asile à ce qu'il
mérite ça il nous reste une minute avant
la fin de cette première année en bosnie
après les mines skis après vous
commencez à deuxième partie tous les
soins ne sont pas gratuits contrairement
à ce qui était un petit peu détaillé
prix de comédie médicale d'état se
calmait pas de prendre tous les soins
gratuitement
est-ce que vous avez alors en guerre est
ce que vous avez des questions du public
en france parce que vous avez l'âme non
sucré lyonnais à l'histoire il faut
quand même vérifier aussi quelques
pièces connues ou non supprimer le
relais mais le ticket modérateur en vous
avez entièrement gratuite c'est que on
ne parle jamais aussi des apports de
l'immigration qu'est ce qu'apporte
l'immigration autres pays en matière de
recherche en matière de création
d'activité que nous ne parlons en
migration d'obasi l'immigration non ce
ne soit pas d'immigration choisie je
parle de ce que la cl une génération a
apporté la france est en retrait son jeu
vous comme sur cette phrase de gandhi ou
pas ce qui nous reste quinze secondes
avant les informations de midi mais on
se retrouve juste après pour une
deuxième partie de l'émission merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir déjà exploité
cette partie du débat on se retrouve
juste après information de midi dans une
fois dix minutes est tout de suite